avant d'accueillir quatre anciens droit
on va se faire à qui a la plus courte en
une fois savez quoi on va jouer direct
pour le son de glace je sais que c'est
quoi le jeu il est très sain on va tirer
chacun un morceau de bois
celui qui aura le morceau de bois le
plus court prendra ce sont deux glaces
dans le dos fait que j'ai un confrère
jusqu'après c'est pas grave tu seras
froid tu es tu deviendras chaud c'est
l'économie la façon la plus pourrie que
j'ai jamais entendu cela est-ce que je
suis un ami dans un poteau de fou voilà
donc tu sais que la confiance
oui c'est ça même si tu perds t'inquiète
pas alors attention par sochaux alors on
y va
choisissez sur une fois on dit c'est
ouais moi j'suis vraiment se dire je
commence à les y frédéric tout le monde
joue
[ __ ] je la pousse alors on verra on
verra après attendent et on verra après
moi je la sens très mal
oui quand même
babychou croyons qu'il est plus grande
bala m bala je vous jure tu sais pas
mais ça c'est plus petits moyens
derrière différente eh ben ça va jouer
entre vous deux vous savez vous des dans
la mer les gars alors j'invite les gens
et à tous et moi tu es l'un vertes note
aussi la journée censée lancer le truc
ah bah ça peut être moins excellente
série a perdu au faîte du toit c'est toi
c'est toi youssoupha malheureuse voie la
plus courte et youssoupha youssoupha
comme tu l'as dit je vais te faire un
petit je vais te faire un petit nom mais
je vais t'en faire un petit et allez
c'est parti
m
à ce qu'on voulait
on joue pour fuir le débat n'en démord
pas d'accord je fais ce que j'ai un jeu
moi tout ça en même temps d'y enfermer à
l'est la raison allait fermer ma gueule
pourquoi tu n'as pas peur du travail
aulas apparemment je suis je suis sauvé
les gars federica je fais le petit mais
je vais vraiment dans la plus con
est ce que mon père était alors allons y
ont fait une dernière
allez c'est parti ah oui je la sens bâle
là je la sens bâle instinct non non non
il est capable dans le nord s'il est
capable maintenant là non
c'est pas un peu du lait
bayal